[Musique]
le gratin des arts visuels s'étaient
donné rendez vous au vernissage de cindy
phoenix sur ça vraiment intéressant très
différent de ce qu'on voit
habituellement ce que j'ai beaucoup tu
travailles de cindy c'est la pratique
qui en arrière toute la démarche qu'elle
offre et comme un fait un lien
intéressant entre la politique et le
féminisme la matérialité
l'artiste de 30 ans est sur une lancée
ses oeuvres ont été acquises par
plusieurs collectionneurs incluant le
musée des beaux-arts la caisse de dépôt
et de placement ou encore hydro-québec
et jeunes enfants qu'ils savaient la
banlieue de montréal vers 11-12 ans mes
parents m'ont inscrit dans les cours le
prince 26 heures du matin et depuis elle
en me fait du chemin en 2015
elle a été finaliste du concours
canadien de peinture rb6 mais il y avait
une manière de paix d'une puissance
lyrique danse physique était vraiment
surprenant elle a pourtant hésité avant
douzy rêver à une carrière d'artiste
sachant que des fois le mandat c'est un
peu comme un bon espoir je trouve quand
et comment intégrer un gros après ses
études à concordia
elle a reçu 200 mille dollars de bourses
pour faire sa maîtrise à la prestigieuse
université north west end à chicago une
formation qui renforce ses convictions
féministes les femmes très peu d'actes
ou d'affirmer cours de la mosaïque dans
la salle de musique
j'ai comme une hiérarchie s'est un peu
qualifiés une démarche et une réflexion
qui arrive au bon moment selon la
conservatrice du mac
elle réussit à bien catalyser un certain
contexte social contexte social qu'on
pourrait voir comme une forme
d'expression nisme en dessus cindy
phoenix a le vent dans les voiles mais
reste prudente
je rends compte en haute corse
andré parant passe consciente que dans
ce domaine l'important n'est pas de
briller mais de durée ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal